who is Dylan Mulvaney
nobody seems to have any idea who this
guy is but we see him everywhere this is
the guy who was virtually unknown and
then he decided that he was going to
become a woman and then 221 days later
he was interviewing the president of the
United States
sitting there in a dress
pretending to be a woman talking about
women's issues with the supposed leader
of the Free World and this just exploded
people's minds
and and there are all sorts of theories
going around as to how this unknown
person became such a phenomenon so
quickly and some people think it has to
do with social media and there's just
something about the social media culture
that allows a figure like this to just
explode out of nowhere people think
rightly to some degree that this has to
do with the transgender movement it's
all just about the rise of
transgenderism but everybody seems to be
missing
the most obvious Point here
Dylan Mulvaney is an actor
he is an actor I don't mean that to say
that Dylan Mulvaney is faking it or
something or that he doesn't really
think that he's a woman that was another
theory that cropped up is that Dylan
Mulvaney is just the greatest troll of
all time and he's just revealing how
ridiculous the transgender ideology is
because on his very first video Dylan
Mulvaney comes out and he says okay I've
been a woman for 10 hours and I've
already cried like three times day one
of being a girl and I have already cried
three times I wrote a scathing email
that I did not send I ordered dresses
online that I couldn't afford and then
uh when someone asked me how I was I
said I'm fine when I wasn't fine
how'd I do ladies because and he just
keeps performing all of these
caricatures of women that are very
offensive to a lot of women but are
generally kind of funny so people think
well he's just faking it I don't think
he's just Faking It
I think Dylan Mulvaney is an actor
and the reason that people are missing
this is one they haven't Googled the guy
and he he is a trained actor he attended
the Cincinnati Conservatory of Music
from musical theater he had a pretty
good career working around New York he
played one of the roles in Book of
Mormon on Broadway that's a pretty big
deal and then then the pandemic hit and
then the lockdowns hit but even before
the lockdowns Apparently Dylan Mulvaney
was a little bit upset at the limits
that were being placed on him as an
actor because he he still could only
play male roles and so the reason I
think that his being an actor is Central
here is because
of modern acting Theory this is
something you wouldn't understand if
you're not familiar with modern acting
Theory and what happened but modern
acting Theory
represents a major psychological break
with old forms of the theater and I
think it actually leads people into all
sorts of craziness and helps to explain
what the guy is actually doing modern
acting Theory and technique began in
America in the 1930s with something
called the group theater Lee Strasburg
was probably the most famous of these
acting teachers who who popularized the
method you you would know Lee Strasbourg
from Godfather Part Two he plays Hyman
Roth he's the Jewish gangster this is
the business we've chosen but this this
technique was controversial even as Lee
Strausberg was developing it and
teaching it at my own teacher who knew
Strasbourg and worked with Strasbourg
win hanman he referred to Lee Strasberg
as a pervert and a voyeur because what
what he was doing on on stage and in his
classes was probing so deeply into the
psychology of of his students and of his
actors that he would he would push
buttons rip off old scabs
create and and play on various passions
and lusts and desires even if they were
not healthy for the individual in the
old school of acting the classical
school of acting uh actors have never
been particularly respected by Society
they've often been lumped in with
prostitutes and criminals but but in the
old school at the very least an actor
could go out on stage with a costume on
play his part and then take the costume
off in the new school of acting the
costume is is not on the outside that's
sort of incidental to the performance
the costume is on the inside that the
costume that the the thing that
demarcates the character and delineates
the character is in the the actor's own
psychology and frankly in the actor's
own soul that you're bending your own
desires such that when you are on stage
you really are feel feeling the things
that the character is supposed to feel
you really are thinking the things that
the character is supposed to think you
really are Desiring things that the
character is supposed to desire and so
it is much more transformative of the
person and depending on how well you can
control this sort of technique
can really warp and an individual sense
of self uh at least rosberg was not the
only guy working on this new natural
style of acting the other members of the
group theater were people like Sanford
Meisner Ilya Kazan Stella Adler Harold
klerman udahogan lots of other people
and what they were doing was creating an
American version of what was called
stanislavsky's system it's this Russian
guy who ran the Moscow Art Theater at
the end of the 19th century and
stanislavski Rises up not just
coincidentally I think around the same
time as Freud and what are both of these
men working on what both of these men
are doing are are
they're turning the focus uh when
they're thinking about human behavior
away from outside forces away from class
away from social role away from manners
and moral order and all the rest of that
and tradition and they're turning it in
on the inner psychology for Freud that
would be obvious basically the psyche of
his patients and for stanislavski this
would be the inner life of the character
so to really oversimplify it the old
kind of acting technique is much more
about taking the outside
and and bringing that in and having the
the external elements create the
performance whereas the new acting
technique is all about the inner life
and having the inner life impel all
sorts of behaviors on the stage and it
sounds kind of pie in the sky so to
bring it down to earth a good example of
this would be a Streetcar Named Desire
if you ever saw the movie Streetcar
Named Desire you've got one actor from
the old school and one actor from The
New School you've got Vivian Lee
probably the greatest actress of her age
in that old classical style of acting
and then you've got Marlon Brando who is
the greatest actor of his age maybe of
any age in the new naturalistic style of
acting and when they're in scenes
together the difference is so Stark
Vivian Lee is there I'm you know this is
the woman from Gone With the Wind she's
so theatrical and so over the top and so
mannered in her acting and then you have
Brando there and there's this kind of
mumbling
and you say you think of Brando and on
the waterfront it was my brother Charlie
he's gonna look down for me I could have
been a contender I couldn't have been
something and it this is the in this
modern style of acting you will often
see people begin to mumble a lot more
this is why it's kind of annoying when
you watch Modern shows sometimes it's
hard to hear what the actors are saying
because the emphasis is so on naturalism
and one of the consequences of this new
style of acting is that it it can mess
up people's psychology a fair bit a
classic Showbiz story of this is when
Dustin Hoffman and Lawrence Olivier were
doing Marathon Man and according to the
story Dustin Hoffman shows up to the set
and he hasn't slept in three days
because he's he's been preparing for
this role and for the role he's got to
be under slept and disheveled and all
that of sorts and so what does he do he
actually does that with his own body
and he shows up and he's complaining
about this on the set and Lawrence
Olivier who's a great example of the old
school of acting just turns to him and
he says my boy have you considered
acting and you don't actually have to do
all of this stuff you can you can just
try acting you can just sort of play
pretend another story with Dustin
Hoffman actually was from uh I have a
little bit of insight on this because
though I'm ashamed to say it in my
wayward youth I worked as an actor
and I trained as an actor with one of
the very famous teachers of this kind of
new school of acting guy named Wynn
hanman who was Sanford meisner's
assistant in the 1950s and who actually
was Dustin Hoffman's teacher and he
tells this story of he was directing a
play in Dustin Hoffman was in the play
and he he had to be cleaning a fish on
stage and so in the old representational
kind of acting what would you do you
just kind of pretend but in the new
style of acting you want everything to
be real and organic and so it's a very
tiny theater Dustin Hoffman's cleaning
the fish there's bone wounds and guts
going into the audience you know
everyone's kind of grossed out by it but
that's what it's all about it's all
about this very real inner life you are
not just approaching a role and saying
what would this character do I don't
know he'd raises he'd wear a hat like
this and he'd move his arm like this no
you're thinking what does this make me
feel like what does this remind me of in
my own life what what is this wound that
I'm going to pick open and this is why a
lot of the famous method actors of the
modern era have had a lot of
psychological problems actors have
always been crazy but actors in this new
naturalistic style seem to be a lot more
crazy Marlon Brando had all sorts of
problems you think of people like Philip
Seymour Hoffman you think of people like
Joaquin Phoenix you think of people out
of all of these kinds of modern actors
uh who you think of Heath Ledger after
playing The Joker I mean this kind of
absolute messing up of one psyche okay
and and this didn't arise out of nowhere
it's not just that one day in 1897
Sigmund Freud and Constantine
stanislavski decided to upend the way
that the West viewed itself uh this was
a process that was developing in the
19th century as all forms of Art became
much more personal you see the
development of the novel it began to
turn the attention away from the
external circumstances of society
and in on the personality and desires
and and dreams of the the individual
and you see this reflected in the
society broadly by the end of the 19th
century you're seeing a breaking down
of Europe and Russia as well of the West
which had been formal and had formal
social roles
and if you were a man you were going to
act this way
if you're a woman
's way and if you were a man of a
certain class you were going to behave
one way and if you were of a lower class
you would act another way you see hear
the rise of feminism
around this time also reflected in the
American Theater through plays like a
dollhouse a head of gobbler and lots of
other plays as well you see this
speaking of women and speaking of plays
from around this time this this new kind
of acting in a very famous Moment
recounted by Sanford Meisner in his book
on acting and he's recounting a story
that he was told by George Bernard Shaw
who was a very well-known socialist
playwright around this era as well
George Bernard Shaw goes to see a play
called Magda
and in this play is one of the famous
actresses of her age eleanora duza and
in the scene dooza is is meeting her
ex-lover 25 years later and the ex-lover
shows up and hands her a bouquet of
flowers and as Shaw is watching this
scene
duza blushes on stage
this astounds shot and she didn't do it
every night of the performance
but she blushed and this was so amazing
because it shows you that this new style
of acting does work it's not just all a
bunch of pretentious gobbledygook it
actually does push buttons in in one's
psyche you can't fake that it's not as
though she had a makeup brush come out
from the ceiling and put blush on her
something from within her actually made
her blush and so what does all of this
have to do with Dylan Mulvaney
what the new style of acting has led to
is far greater naturalism in the theater
a kind of naturalism that would have
been bizarre to earlier audiences
because earlier audiences were just less
naturalistic in their behavior they were
less casual in their behavior they were
much much more formal in their social
structures as that breaks down it's
reflected in the theater it's reflected
in all of our personal lives and so you
see far greater naturalism it's what
dominates today it's what every single
actor in the world is trained in today
it's all audiences have come to expect
today and what what that what that
naturalism tells you and what that
building of the inner life tells you
that Focus so much on the inner life of
the character tells you is that you can
play any character you want
anybody can be anybody that he wants to
be
you don't have to look a certain way you
don't have to be of a certain race you
don't have to be a certain height you
don't have to be a certain sex you can
just women can play men men can play
women
black guys can play White characters
white white guys are still not allowed
to play Black characters and that's
owing to political correctness what do
you mean
but you can be whatever you want
and so again it's it's not just one
aspect of art taken out of broader
social trends and psychological Trends
this is reflected everywhere we are told
in our society you can be whatever you
want to be you have no obligations to
anybody you have no limitations
whatsoever if if you are a pygmy you can
play in the NBA someday if you are a
dunce you can be a mathematician you
can't but but this is the sort of thing
that we tell ourselves if you're a man
you can be a woman if you're a woman you
can be a man and so Dylan Mulvaney
reflects in an interview with LA
magazine he was very upset he said the
theater industry was incredibly gendered
and he was only able to get male roles
well that's not fair he can build up the
inner life of any character he wants and
maybe he even feels a little bit like a
woman why doesn't he get to play female
roles
in comes the covid lockdowns and when
the coveted lockdowns strike Dylan
Mulvaney is taken out of the Broadway
theaters and now he is left locked up in
his room
with a new stage the stage is tick tock
so the stage is the most intimate and
Open Stage you can possibly have he can
be whoever he wants to be on the stage
of tick tock and he decides that he is
going to be a woman and he instantly
picks up nine million followers he's got
over 9 million followers right now
he does this series called days of
girlhood he builds a character just like
any actor does and he ends up getting
sponsorships he ends up now becoming the
sort of social phenomenon so much so
that he's sitting down with the
president of the United States
why because in the old school
of acting and in the old school of our
society
people were expected to do the sorts of
things that were prescribed for their
roles
their roles on stage and their roles
just in society
today
people are expected to do whatever their
inner psychological State impels them to
do according to the old school
the way to give a good performance on
the stage and in life
was to
fulfill one's duty according to one's
external circumstances
according to the new school
in order to perform Your Role correctly
on stage and in life you you have to
ignore the external circumstances you
have to ignore all of the demands of the
society and only follow what is
supposedly your authentic inner
psychological State even if that inner
psychological state is utterly divorced
from the physical world
that is what is happening
in our society on our stages on our Tick
Tock watching this man wearing a dress
sit across from Joe Biden what is he who
is Dylan Mulvaney is he a troll is he a
transgender phenomenon is he a social
media phenomenon no he is the greatest
actor of Our Generation
he is fully inhabiting the role he is
the natural flowering of modern acting
technique which is the flowering
of our modern view of psychology
which is the flowering of the collapse
of Western Civilization at its height
that's it you got it right there
who knows what star will appear tomorrow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]